Selena Gomez once sang I want a
boyfriend
well seemed cell found a good one in The
Chainsmokers Drew tagger
[Music]
okay not so fast but ET can confirm
Selena and Drew are dating thesaurus
tell us ET they met through mutual
friends in a friendly low-key way but
had an instant connection and liked each
other as people quote they've been
talking ever since and they're into each
other you never know who you're gonna
make magic with so Selena and Drew first
sparked dating rumors after page six
obtained photos of them on a bowling
date in New York City an eyewitness
claims the pair was making out while
enjoying their time on the lanes oh my
goodness Selena's new romance comes
nearly a month after A source told E.T
she was feeling positive and optimistic
about her love life and that she was
open to dating I think it's nice to have
a little bit something to myself yeah
seems sells 30 flirty and thriving
because back in July shortly after her
30th birthday another source told E.T
she's also very much focused on herself
and her work right now and added quote
she's in a very healthy Place she's
feeling fantastic and very mentally
physically and emotionally healthy I'm
constantly somebody that likes to grow
and feel like all right what could I be
better at what could I do better at
where where could my confidence be
stronger as for Drew he was most
recently linked to Steve Jobs 24 year
old daughter Eve last summer he didn't
name names but he recently shared on the
call her daddy podcast that he was in a
relationship with someone that didn't
exactly start off on the right foot we
got set up on a date
a year ago fun and it was the worst date
either of us had ever been on not fun
yeah it was just like zero Vibes just
misconnection and didn't see each other
for I think like six months after that
and then last summer I just kept running
into each other and then the Bad Day
become became like a fun conversation
point and we like hit it off on like the
Fourth of July as for cell well she's
been relatively quiet about her love
life since breaking up with the weekend
in October 2017 and since then she
hasn't been afraid to poke fun at her
single status I'm very honest though in
general yeah and we've seen it firsthand
on tick tock no I'm fine I'm totally
fine being single it's a real thing it's
fine
[Music]
last time I was single I was 24 and the
dating pool was everyone and now it's
like a shallow puddle of age-appropriate
men who are old and gross and I don't
want to do that and on live TV I've
heard that SNL is a great place to find
Romance I'm manifesting love and I would
like to say that I'm looking for my
soulmate but at this point I will take
anyone fast forward to 2023 and it seems
cell manifested something
[Music]
our source says things are still new
with Drew but they're having so much fun
getting to know one another
[Music]